la folie du floorball s'est emparé de
buc ce samedi 17 et dimanche 18 février
la ville a accueilli le premier tournoi
de cette discipline organisée dans les
yvelines un sport à porter tout droit
des pays scandinaves
c'est comme vieux quai sur glace mais
sans patins sans la patinoire comme du
hockey sur gazon mais à l'intérieur du
coup on est sur l'équivalent d'un
terrain de hand-ball donc avec les mêmes
basket avec une crosse et et on est au
chaud ce jour là six équipes se sont
affrontées au gymnase du prés saint jean
dont l'équipe locale des jays de buc
sur le terrain les matchs durent trois
fois vingt minutes avec des pousses de
cinq minutes entre chaque tir tant en
cours tout le temps des d'une part et
d'autre du terrain deux minutes par par
shift et puis ensuite on repart se
reposer un petit peu sur le banc avant
de rentrer il faut pas mal de kério de
rapidité
donc il faut pas un minimum en fait de
conditions sportives et en faisant du
floorball du court la développe aussi
comme pour le hockey sur glace les
équipes sont composées de cinq joueurs
plus un gardien ce dernier reste tout le
match sur le terrain
un poste clé pour remporter la victoire
qu'elle était principal c'est d'avoir
beaucoup de réflexes aussi d'avoir de
l'anticipation pour voir d'où arrive la
balle qu'elle arrive de loin qu'elle
arrive de proches qu'elles arrivent par
un joueur un petit peu décalé c'est le
jeu aussi des adversaires de cette
boucher la vue du gardien est donc
vraiment beaucoup de réflexes d arrêt
réflexe des gardiens qui ont conquis le
public de buc et la folie du floorball
n'est pas près de s'arrêter
elle semble même se propager aux
nouvelles générations de la commune